[Arabic recitation]
wasallam
yaji'una
li salat
fil masjid fayu sallun
thumma yajlisu fil masjid yantaziruna
al-isha
[Arabic recitation]
the companions of the prophet salallahu
alayhi wasallam
speaking about the elder companions
Abdullah ibn Mas'ud Abu Bakr Umar Uthman
Ali ibn Abi Talib the veteran
companions
would come and make salatul Maghrib
behind the prophet salallahu alayhi
wasallam
in the masjid.
And then they would sit in the masjid
and wait for salatul Isha.
And as they would sit waiting for
salatul Isha
you would look at many of them and see
their chin
in their chest.
And you could hear them snoring.
Could hear them snoring as they're
sitting up.
They've been working all day. A lot of
them have been awake since Fajr.
They come to make salat in the in the
masjid in Maghrib. They don't go back
home
which is one of the reasons why the time
between Maghrib and Isha is so short.
And they would wait for Isha and they
would fall asleep sometimes in the
masjid waiting for salatul Isha.
He says and then the prophet salallahu
He says, "And then the prophet sal
[Arabic recitation]
for Isha
and they would stand up and make salah
and not make wudu again."
So, here we have them doing this.
We have them seeing each other do this.
[Arabic recitation]
wasallam seeing them
do this.
And
[Arabic recitation]
narration
as a custom.
He uses words in the narration that
articulate
habit.
Kanu yaji'una.
[Arabic recitation]
Bi ma'ana kana hadha al-shay' yahduth
yahduthu.
And so, what do we understand from this
narration?
We understand from this narration that
this is what kind of sleep? Deep or
light sleep?
Light sleep.
And if it was if it were deep sleep,
they would have gone and made wudu.
But light sleep
even if there is a sound of snoring.
Have you ever fallen asleep and woken
yourself up snoring?
Maybe not the younger men, the older
men.
Me, I'm not
innocent of that.
Right? I woken myself up snoring many
times. This is an indicator of what kind
of sleep?
Light sleep. Light sleep. Heavy sleep,
you'd never wake up.
[Arabic recitation]
wasallam
it was customary and known
of is that he would have a light snore
when he would sleep alayhi salat wa
salam.
So,
[Arabic recitation]
mentions. It's not here in this
chapter. The author doesn't mention
this narration in this chapter.
The name of the book implies
you know, implies a summary.
al-wajiz
However, he will mention it in future
chapters.
So, we have the first
and second invalidators of wudu.
Number one, al-kharij min as-sabilayn.
Number two,
an-nawm
al-mustaghriq
an-nawm mustaghriq
deep sleep
and
anything that comes out of the
private parts. The author then mentions
a third invalidator of wudu. And
honestly, this third invalidator of wudu
relates to the one just mentioned, which
is deep sleep.
He says,
ath-thalithu
zawalul aqli bi sukrin aw maradin
li anna dhuhul inda hadhihil asbab
ablaghu minan nawmil mustaghriq.
He says the third invalidator of wudu
is is
that the mind
becomes clouded and a person loses
consciousness.
He loses awareness. He loses
Whether it be because of a drug, whether
it be because of a fall, whether it be
because of an illness,
whether it be for any number of reasons,
this is an invalidator of wudu. For the
same reason
that deep sleep is an invalidator
of wudu.
A person goes for anesthesia,
goes for a minor surgery,
a person
breaks something and the pain is so
severe that they pass out,
a person loses consciousness, a person
takes some kind of medication or some
kind of drug,
or a person becomes intoxicated,
whether purposely or unpurposely or or
un- un-
unintentionally.
these are all things that will break
a person's wudu. For the same reason
that a naum mustaghriq breaks a person's
wudu.
The next thing that he mentions is
massul farj min ghayri ha'ilin idhaa
kaana bi shahwah.
Touching the private parts
without a barrier, so skin on skin,
if it is out of lust.
This is what the author mentions. Now,
we are going to debate this issue.
The evidences in this
area, in this aspect, are numerous
and the conversation regarding this is a
little bit detailed.
So, we will speak about this tomorrow,
inshallah.
Nas'alullah subhanahu wa ta'ala
an yu'allimana
min deenina ma jahilna wa an yufaqqihana
fee I better that dinner will feed
dinner.
When I sell to
a lot of you guys are doing the Akbar.
I mean I would have a map below I mean I
will allow
us a lot of what sell them a lot of them
a lot of them.